he's a busy man and was kind enough to
give us a couple minutes here today on
this busy friday he is uh one of the
best in the business and i'm not just
saying that because i work with them all
the time on the nfl media group ian
rappaport at rap sheet here on the rich
housing show how you doing ian
i'm good how are you guys i am doing
well so jj what is this possible that
we're going to see him
week uh
week 19 right uh maybe a playoff game in
dallas or or a home playoff game should
things break their way
into it full transparency uh you were
expected to hear about this on sunday
morning on game day morning for the
first time then the cardinals decided to
designate him for return
today which
was very much appreciated not really um
but anyway yes uh so jj watt who tore
his labrum and his rotator cuff and his
bicep oh my god is
is a miracle uh i mean he from what i
understand he has been pushing his rehab
insanely hard
so he knows his body better than anyone
and he has been pushing to the absolute
brink and because of that
he has been able to
rehab faster than anyone imagine so
instead of several months instead of
four months or six months it is going to
be a matter of weeks the plan as of now
is for him to be out on the field
for the first week of the playoffs
rather than the super bowl which is what
he was originally playing
oh my goodness gracious so that's
that's what a what a major boon that
would be what about deandre hopkins what
about getting everybody back the whole
band back together
go on the mission here
what do you think with hopkins it
doesn't seem nearly as positive he had a
mcl tear and the knee was really
unstable
um so you know possible but i would say
unlikely
when i talk to people close to hopkins
you know that sounds like
some people are like yeah we could get
them back and they told people close to
hopkins it's like oh man that was a
really serious injury so i don't get a
as good a feeling on hopkins
maybe for the super bowl maybe
but i
it doesn't seem very likely for me
ian rap report here on the rich eisen
show let's move to tampa
um what about their
injuries and their bumps and
bruises and even worse than that can
they get everybody who's not done for
the season back in time you think for a
playoff game
next weekend what do you think i don't i
don't know about everybody because
ronald jones ankle seems to be far more
serious than people realize
he hasn't even running yet so the
thought of him being back next week i
don't know if that's going to happen
but it does seem like leonard
fournette's going to be back it seems
like mike evans is going to be fine
um chris godwin is out
and then levante david that was a foot
sprain so that's like kind of tricky so
i think he has a chance to get back but
you know obviously looking at the way it
happened last year like this is very
very different right i mean last year
they were rolling i think if you know if
you took a poll last year and you said
which of the
you know not top rated teams presents
the biggest danger like some people
would have taken the bucks just because
they kind of were like
you know rolling in on on a high horse
for the playoffs it's not like that this
year um you know they they have tom
brady i don't know if you heard that
they have tom brady so they could still
get it together
um but a b you know as crazy as as
everything turned out like he's a very
good football player and using him
really does hurt
so now that dust has settled and and uh
i guess now that the teams are like okay
you're gonna put everything on your
instagram and you're on twitter we'll
start talking as well so what happened
in the last week you know soup to nuts
over the last couple weeks
soup tonight okay so with him let's go
back to last wednesday okay so which is
uh nine days ago not this past wednesday
yep so
he asked the bucks to guarantee one
million dollars of his incentives he was
going to get it anyway but he wanted it
guaranteed
maybe because his foot wasn't feeling
but anyway he wanted a guarantee they
said we're not going to do that because
um
they they just they don't do that right
so he was upset and they didn't practice
wednesday thursday and they didn't think
on oh sorry didn't practice thursday
friday they didn't think on friday that
he was going to be able to go
saturday he looks good at the walk
through shoots up his ankle for sunday
and then comes in the locker room after
getting targeted four times in the first
half and throws a fit
and says he doesn't want to play on the
sidelines when b when ba and other
coaches target him they eject him from
the sidelines you know like kind of like
an umpire just tossing a guy
and essentially he was cut there
and then
they tried to get him some help
counseling and others which is why they
hadn't cut him previously
and then finally yesterday after he
decided to post some very nice text
messages from everyone
which i think maybe he thought they
would mean but they actually were very
nice uh then they decided to cut him
yesterday hmm and so uh it was about
money is that what this is about
is you know what because again because
it's cause aaron's because aryans did
clearly know about his ankle right i
mean he sent a photograph of his ankle
and so i mean he also missed practice
thursday friday right so everyone knew
then and like they've been you know they
i know they were frustrated with his
rehab and how attentive he was before
this
so they knew about his ankle and no no i
i know that but the reason why maybe he
said i don't know if it was his ankle or
not
you know is because they might have that
might have been well if he was not
playing because of his money and he's
upset that he wasn't playing because of
his money
that might have been a reason for it as
well
right you know what i mean like and i'm
not sitting here trying to cover for
anybody because clearly this
relationship despite them keeping him uh
was sour
no question right
and now it's not cover though because
you know everything deserves an
explanation and so like the ankle thing
only makes sense in the context of like
it was the last straw
because clearly he you know like he
could say what he wants about them
pushing him to play you read those test
messages it doesn't seem like they're
pushing him to play
clearly he wanted to play he's the one
who shot up his ankle
and he wanted to reach his incentives
but you know
i would say
it always is money
whenever whenever there's a question the
answer is usually money and with antonio
brown for most of his disputes money has
been at the root of it and it seems like
at least money plays a big part in it
here as well well and what about all the
things that he was alleging through his
lawyer i mean where does that stand are
there grievances are there is there what
do you know about all of that
to finish up
a lot
and i don't know what the grievances
would be
because it's not like there's you know
it's like is he gonna do a grievance
for
sixty thousand dollars
like i you know because that's what it
would be a one week salary but he's
gonna get it anyway because he was on
the roster wednesday so like
i don't even know and he can't grieve
you know about incentives because it
doesn't work like that so like i don't
know that he could claim
to get any money anyway
so i don't even think it's about that
ian rappaport uh here on the rich eisen
show uh in whatever time i have left
with you let's just hit on on coaching
vacancies um because i'm sure that's
what's burning your phone up for sure
monday's the day that we'll find out or
sunday nights the day night that we'll
find out how do you see it all shaking
out
ian
in the nfl um
so to me the thrill to watch and this is
not like a total surprise it seems
pretty clear this year is you know
denver minnesota and chicago and you
know obviously jaguars the raiders is
open
bill bryan is going to interview with
the jaguars
uh which everyone seems to think it's
funny i don't know why that's funny like
he was a very very good coach before he
decided to try his hand at personnel
um or whatever
um
and so you know i would say
you know maggie is as we've talked about
on game day morning nagi is likely gone
and then i would say fangio and zimmer
are pretty up in the air um you know
both are in doubt
i think both will have to make cases to
stay but it doesn't sound like a firm
decision has been made
but we could have just five openings
this year
um
which you know would be a little on the
low side but it doesn't seem like
there's a can't miss candidates so that
makes sense as well what's your
reporting on my college coach and
harbaugh what do you got for that for me
on that you know i i
i would say to me it seems like he's in
a similar situation as last year where
you know is he interested in looking
looking at the greener grass in the nfl
i think he's probably would look
um
it seems to me and i don't mean this in
any way toward anything that was
reported
but
when someone takes a pay cut
and then gets to shove it where the sun
would no longer like to shine
usually it's like we just said usually
it's about money right so yes he said
all the very nice things about pay cut
but is he using the leverage of the
media to say have like a lot more money
or i'll go to the nfl yeah i'm not
saying that's what's behind it but i'm
just saying
you know
that makes a lot of sense and is the
jaguars job uh more difficult to fill
because they they're keeping their
general manager is that uh also part of
what you're sensing or hearing despite
trevor lawrence's remarkable talent are
you hearing that you know
i i think it's maybe not for everyone
um like for those who need a perfect
situation like josh mcdaniels like that
might not be the great place for him
but
it doesn't mean it's specific to trent
balke some people just would want a
clean slate
so
you know i
based on the list of people they've
targeted i don't know that there's any
right now that would not take it if
trent balkey is there ian rappaport
thanks for the time i know you're jammed
brother really appreciate the 10 minutes
see you said 10 minutes i gave you you
gave me 10 minutes and i'm i'm not i'm
not one of those guys that you can told
you oh this is kind of a jewish goodbye
right now but you know um thank you
that's what it feels like right now i
just don't wanna let you go you know
like how's everything like
about it my mom
like okay anyway and let me just tell
you this other six stories i'm like
thanks mom
thanks for calling appreciate it take
care okay thank you there you go
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here